I'm glad that you and Andy have put
aside your differences let me explain
what's going on
you shoot clipped here on the lot say
that we work on Andy called you out on
Twitter for parking your car did badly
in the parking lot here and he sent this
out to the entire world Dale it's your
parking spot and was someone late for
rehearsal Andy's wanderings it looks
like you pulled in at about 80 miles an
hour but you and you took a lot of flack
for this right I did I did and actually
that's not even in my car so yes I'll
explain what happened it's George whenst
car who's my co-star he's George you
know from here so um I was parked in his
space for some reason and then he parked
in that space so Andy took a picture
sent that out and like all the blog
sites picked up that was like this
horrible Parker yeah okay so Andy don't
you feel it's your job to investigate
further before you just blindly start
tweeting stuff out into the universe and
I was worried for a moment when I found
it it was George's car but that when I
found out the reason George part that
was in that spot was cuz you just parked
in his spot Ashley parks wherever Ashley
wants to Eddie wonders a lot like a
stuck-up librarian looking for trouble
[Applause]
you don't get it half as bad as those
pretty little liar I'm glad we
straightened it out